- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my goodness.
- [Kelly] You look very dapper.
- You're very sweet.
You look very beautiful.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you,
it's a team of people.
- Same here.
I love that you have a
Botox station in the back.
(Kelly laughs)
I feel so good.
- Then I haven't used it.
- And your audience is so beautiful.
- They're here without masks.
(audience cheering)
It has taken us, I love
that you noticed that,
it has taken a minute
to get here, Michael.
So yeah.
- I noticed the second I
was watching on the monitor.
I saw a guy out there, I
don't know where he is now,
but he was so, he had a
blue shirt and suspenders,
and I thought, look at how,
- You can see his smile.
- There he is.
Look at you, dude.
- [Kelly] You can see his smile.
- [Michael] You look so lovely today.
- He looks so cool.
Wait, the last time we saw each other,
I know we've run into
each other several times,
but the last time, was it at "The Voice"?
I don't remember.
- I think so and then the time before,
I think we had dinner with Blake.
- [Kelly] Yeah, with Blake.
At Coy?
- Coy or somewhere.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that was fun.
- Yeah, it was fun.
- We all drank, it was good.
- [Michael] I think my
sisters came and everything.
- Yeah, it was good.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- I love their food.
Well, congrats, though,
you have a new baby now.
Is it four?
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Y'all make some babies.
- Thank you, well you too.
You make beautiful babies.
- Yes, but two.
- Yeah.
I think once you hit two, three.
- They start playing with each other,
and so yeah, that's kind of helpful.
- So yeah, my wife, we're
really excited to be expecting.
I'm really lucky that she loves me.
- Did you want a fourth
or was it like a oopsie?
Like was it?
- It was, you know what,
I wanted the fourth,
but it was, it definitely was a whoopsie.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I'm just saying, most,
I feel like most, sometimes
third or fourths are.
- No, we wanted it.
I think I just was more excited.
I'm digging myself into a deep hole.
(Kelly laughing)
- So she was more excited than you.
- Well, I like the part
about making it so much.
(Kelly laughing)
I think that's the part
that I was really into that.
- Touche, touche, yeah.
- And then, what's really funny,
so on Christmas Eve, we told the kids
and we were like there's a baby coming.
- Yeah.
- And my little boy, Eli, who's five,
I think, you're are seven and--
- Five and seven.
- So the five-year-old, he was devastated
and we were like, ah,
what, you don't want?
And he said no, he said,
"Why didn't you invite me
when you fell in love and made the baby?"
- Oh my gosh!
- And I still don't
know how to answer that.
- 'Cause you don't live in the mountains
and some things you don't share.
We're not that kind of family.
Like it's, yeah.
My kids, they want me to have one.
I constantly come home and they're like,
"Is there a baby in there?"
And I'm like "I know it
might appear so, but no."